the in-house ad campaign that's caused
so much upset around the country
depending on which side of the Divide
you are on
um do you agree with that ad campaign
well I think it's absolutely right that
the labor party is holding the Prime
Minister and the conservatives to
account for their absolute failure to
deal with these serious crimes and these
are the government's own statistics and
that we put them out in the public
domain in a way that has caught people's
attention because it's not right that so
many of these um you know crimes are
going without the level of punishment
that they deserve and that criminals
they're clearly getting away with it you
know we've seen it in burglaries we've
seen it in terms of child sex abuse that
that people feel that the justice system
at the moment is not working for them
and the government is setting the
framework for that and they're
responsible for it and Rishi sunak is
the prime minister
yeah so just to clarify do you support
the tone of these ads because you
haven't tweeted any of them have you I
think they're really hard hitting and I
think there's a reason why that and you
know and people it has caught the
Public's attention and that's what our
intention was was to ensure the public
do see that the Prime Minister and the
conservatives for the last 13 years have
failed to tackle serious crime in the
black criminals off the hook and make no
apologies for that you know I'm somebody
who's known to not hold my bunches and I
think that this is a issue that most
people will be disgusted by and I think
it's right that we've highlighted them
as you say you don't hold back so why
have you not retweeted them
well I was away with my children last
week so I would have said not
necessarily on my social media as much
as I normally would be but I do think
that you know it's right that we
highlight these issues and I'm on your
program today saying exactly the same
that we should be highlighting the
situation with criminals at the moment
who are getting away with it these are
serious crimes and the government and
the prime minister is responsible for
setting the framework for the criminal
justice system and they they failed to
protect the public
yeah you tweeted a lot though haven't
you you've tweeted a lot but you've not
retweeted those
the bottom line is you haven't retweeted
those because you're holding your nose
because you think they're going a bit
far
not at all no I just think that you know
these are hard-hitting hands about the
government's failure on crime and I
think it's right that we highlight that
you know the if you look at those ads
and you look at the figures which are
the government's own figures that we've
taken uh it's pretty appalling and
people will be disgusted by that that
the government's failed to protect
people from serious crime
is um Mr sunax Mrs
um fair game I did put that to Sarah
Brown Gordon Brown's misses obviously
she was in number 10 for a period
um and she said yesterday that politics
is a roller coaster and basically wives
are fair game
well I think it's not necessarily that
you know his wife is fair game the
problem that we've got is Rishi sunak
has benefited from this non-dom status
and his direct family is household at a
time where we're saying that that
loophole should be ended so that we can
pay from all doctors and nurses coming
into our NHS because we see the crisis
unfolding in the NHS at the moment with
the workforce and that's way one way of
funding it so I think it's absolutely
right that we highlight that you know
the prime minister's household is
benefiting from this loophole at a time
where we're saying that we should be
closing that loophole and making sure
that that money is redirected into our
NHS where we need the workforce for the
future we've got Junior doctors on
strike at the moment we've got to work
force a crisis in our NHS and the
government have a choice and wish you
sooner household is benefiting from this
uh non-dom loophole at a time when
actually he's failing to do anything
about it I think that's right to
highlight that what about people who are
benefiting from renting out their second
homes as Holiday Homes what would
Labor's strategy be to improve the
housing stock and still allow people to
rent out their second homes if they
wanted to
well we said that we would um create
more homes more social homes we would
give people first dips when these new
homes are put on the market so that
first-time buyers can get the
opportunity to buy these homes first so
that people who are struggling to get on
the housing ladder can have that
opportunity to do that I think you know
we've got to solve the situation that we
currently face in this country where
many people can't get on the housing
bladder and actually those renters that
are stock invented accommodation are
seeing their rents go up including
mortgages that are going up at the
moment so the cost of living and most
people are now worried that they won't
even be able to afford to get a mortgage
because mortgages have increased because
of the disastrous budget that the list
trust and the conservatives put to the
country recently
okay I know I've got to let you go
you're going to press the retweet button
on some of those ads once you've
finished
no one tells me what street
but I say I will continue to hold the
government to account on their appalling
record and people can see those ads they
can see those figures and they can make
their decision based upon those
government figures that we've put out
about whether or not they've dealt with
serious crime or not okay it's great to
see you thanks for joining us enjoy the
rest of recess thank you thank you